are the airpods Pro 2 really that much
better than the original airpods Pro
well today we will find out because
we're going to compare everything from
the sound quality noise cancellation and
microphones to the battery life new
features and more I gotta say that I've
been waiting for these for about two
years now because the competition is
getting so good and within the last year
I actually switched over to the airpods
3 because they sounded better now one
thing I wish they did add was USB type c
they are still sticking with lighting
and that's a major bummer but instead
they chose to allow you to charge it
with an Apple Watch charger which I
don't really know why they would do that
but thankfully the battery life is up to
30 hours now total with the case in up
to six hours for the earbuds themselves
now the case size looks identical in
both the front and the back look the
same as well but if we take a look at
the side we now have this little port
for a lanyard which I don't really have
a use for but what is useful is the
speaker on the bottom of the case and
we're gonna show that off the first time
I noticed it when I popped it open and I
heard that sound right there and that
just tells you it's ready to pair and
the last difference that not many people
are talking about is the fact that the
case is now also ipx4 water resistant
just like the earbuds where it oh the
old one wasn't and my other pair this
thing completely died because it went
through the wash which sucked because my
Apple Care just expired the buds
themselves have also been slightly
redesigned Apple got rid of the
proximity sensor and they're using a
skin detect sensor and the vent has now
moved up higher let's get these things
paired
wow that was instant I wonder if that's
because of the new H2 chip and the new
Bluetooth 5.3 which my iPhone also has
and we noticed that on the Apple Watch
series 8 and the ultra pairs super fast
while I'm swapping out the ear tips for
the large ones I want to mention they
have extra small now which are tiny but
I have some pretty large ear canals so
I'm gonna go ahead and pop these in
right I'm going to turn off the active
noise cancellation they feel identical
in my ears and the only thing that's
changed as far as controls isability
swipes I want to try that out
all right interesting each time there's
a little thump so it tells you it's
adjusting and as you guys could see I
just swipe up or down and it moves it up
not by that much surprisingly and then
as I'm doing that I am kind of Shifting
the earbuds in my ears unless I'm being
super careful so I don't really know how
useful this is gonna be day to day next
I want to test out the active noise
cancellation and the transparency mode
because the airpods Pro 2 processed 48
000 times a second compared to 200 for
the original airpods Pro now before I
compare the active noise cancellation if
you're buying earpods for your teens or
kids or even if you just have kids our
sponsor wondershare has the perfect
solution to keep him safe the famous
Safe app which not only monitors your
kids phone activity but keeps the web
safe by removing inappropriate content
and it comes with a built-in GPS tracker
as well and right now they're doing a
back to school Campaign which you can
enter by following the rules in the
video description to win up to a
thousand dollars in school supplies so
check out famousave today and get 20 off
by using the link down below turning on
the noise cancellation on the original
airpods Pro it definitely knocks out a
lot of that sound we have an AC vent
right over there but I still hear some
of that low end sound The Originals were
pretty good when they came out but the
last couple of years the competition has
gotten much much better alright the
Moment of Truth all right that's not too
different it's very similar I hear a
little bit less noise my voice is
actually quite a bit different the AC
event I still hear a little bit that low
end Rumble uh but let's go ahead and
make this a little bit more difficult I
turned on some Cafe noise just so we can
have a noisier environment to test in
these are the originals right here
and right away that knocked out a lot of
that low end but the high frequencies
are still fairly present now the new
ones all right there you go
that's much more of a difference
the low end is gone completely and the
high end I still hear a little bit the
eyes are brought down a ton and I can't
really tell kind of what's going on in
the background that is a huge huge
difference here's a little example of
what I heard
all right
now as far as transparency the airpod
pros were the best let's go ahead and
turn that back on sounds amazing but
even go ahead and say something hey
watch your Apple watch Ultra review yes
watch every we tried very hard the
comparison at least you sound perfect I
don't know how they can make this any
better and of course this mode uses the
microphone so if it gets any better I
mean some microphones get better as well
let's take a listen to the new ones
all right Vadim say something subscribe
to Max Tech hey subscribe to Max Tech
but I did notice only one difference my
voice sounds a little bit worse unless
I'm just getting sick because we've been
working way too much but your voice I
get more of that low end uh so it
doesn't make it that much better but
that it does sound more natural so I
guess they did improve it now as far as
microphone quality the original airpods
which I'm using right now they were
never amazing they're okay and lately
they have also been superseded and this
is the microphone quality of the airpods
pro 2. now you guys let me know in the
comments if they sound any better if
they do I think it might be because that
Bluetooth 5.3 and now the moment that
I've been waiting for what I've been
waiting for for years now is better
audio quality so we're going to start
out with the track you guys will see my
expression live we'll go through a
couple of genres let's get started
[Music]
unfamiliar bring me back
[Music]
all right all right I was not
disappointed the difference is not
massive in some of the parts the intro
is very similar uh her voice sounds a
little bit more natural it's not like
that has been turned down just sounds
smoother which is nice but when that
bass kicked in the bass is a lot deeper
and I love that yeah I could hear a lot
of the beacons too did you hear more
leakage yeah like literally hear like
the song really but not with the air
plus pro one no no I could barely hear
it do you think the vent is venting out
a lot more it must be that because I
have the same ear tips on or just a lot
more volume
uh it did get a little bit louder yeah
it did get a little bit louder but not
significantly yeah so it has to be the
venting so if you guys don't like a lot
of leakage and you love maxing out your
speakers your earbuds like I do they're
gonna get louder the next song is kind
of an upbeat modern classical that
sounds way better on my airpods 3 than
my original airpods Pro so I really hope
to see a big difference
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
guys Apple's done a good job and this is
not even the hardest test one thing I
noticed is that in certain parts these
are a lot louder not all the time but
the way the airpods work they have their
adaptive EQ so if something's gonna
distort the volume will get adjusted
down not that you notice a you know
sudden drop off but in certain parts
where there could have been Distortion
with the other one these drivers could
play it now obviously more bass like I
mentioned before but the hi-hat had such
a nice distinct punch almost like a
punch on your face but it's with the
hi-hats and that kind of like a bigger
separation uh from the base so the
drivers are definitely a lot better and
same thing with the sound stage and now
for this really tough rock song with a
bunch of different stuff going on
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
guys for a second there I had this kind
of weird look it almost sounded like
there was something in the background
that maybe should have been there but I
just actually did not notice it at all
with the original airpods it might be
one of those drum little uh I don't know
what they're called like a little whisk
thing on the drum but anyways I heard on
these ones these ones stayed louder as
well which was really nice and
definitely the separation between the
instruments are better now I'm used to
hearing that on my airpods Max as well
it sounds amazing definitely better than
airpods Pro 2 but these are definitely a
step up in every single way I think the
one thing that might be a downside is uh
the tweeters when some parts are a
little bit lower Maybe because there's
more separation I'm not sure I think a
lot of people like that because people
don't like harsh Highs but in general
man the sound quality has absolutely
been improved quite dramatically now one
interesting new thing is this ability to
personalize a spatialized audio this is
going to use the front camera with the
lidar sensor to scan your face and your
ear to make the sound better with the
spatialized mode let's try that out
looks like I'm setting a face ID again
and now it's going to do my right ear
and it's going to shoot a bunch of tiny
lasers in there it actually starts
automatically I can't even see what it's
doing but videos recording it here
ready tell me what it says I don't know
what to do oh geez okay
wow it did it it's done now one thing
you have to know is this is not only for
the airpods pro 2. you can actually do
that with the original airpods Pro as
well to improve spatial audio now I went
ahead and I listened to the song before
we did that so I know how it sounds like
with spatial audio let's take another
listen all right I don't have to listen
to that whole track that was an
improvement the one thing that I noticed
when I tested out the spatial audio
before is the synth once all the other
instruments get smacked in there I
couldn't hear it when I enabled spatial
audio without it sounded better which is
why I rarely use spatial audio now some
of this tracks got louder and that synth
was still audible so who knows maybe I
will use the spatial audio more now and
I think one of the best new features is
the ability to find it with the ultra
wide band chip so here I'm in my find my
app I can go ahead and play a sound on
here or I can click find nearby and it
actually shows me exactly where it is at
and this is amazing because my parents
lost their airpods for a year because it
slid in somewhere and they couldn't find
it and a lot of people use airpods all
the time so that is so awesome to have I
can also play that sound listen to that
that is actually pretty loud that's
definitely louder than an air tag
yeah it's almost as loud as a siren on
the ultra watch just I think the sirens
louder but not as loud as we thought
that is so awesome you guys see that
flashes right there as well if it's dark
you're gonna see that I mean I think
that's such a killer reason to buy the
new airpods Pro 2 if you're trying to
choose between which one to buy and that
leads right into that final Choice
should you upgrade and which one should
you buy well as far as which one should
you buy I think unless you're absolutely
strapped for cash and in that reason you
probably shouldn't be buying the
original airpods Pro anyways I think you
should absolutely get these new ones the
sound quality is better yes the battery
life is better yes but having the
ability to track it that right there is
a 30 value for an air tag but it's built
in with that loud speaker and that can
save you the whole value of the airpods
in case you lose them and then of course
the better sound quality and that much
better active noise cancellation I think
you apps absolutely should spend the
money compared to a discounted pair of
airpods pro 2. with that should you
upgrade if you already have airpods Pro
well I think if you love your airpods
and use them every single day you've had
these for a while you are absolutely
going to enjoy the benefits of the new
ones so if you have the money I would
say yes sell your old ones get some of
that money back and upgrade but if you
just buy your air pods or if you just
use them casually you don't really care
about that extra features well in that
case you're probably not even watching
this video so there you guys go check
out one of those great videos right over
there click above to subscribe if you
guys want to see a follow-up review
after a while of using these every day
this has been Max and I'll see you in
the next video
[Music]
thank you